And now the old scout master.
Here's a thought. of all the animals domesticated and wild,
The scout is the least trainable.
That's from Thoughts on Scouting and you're
going to hear more about that later on in the podcast,
But this is podcast number 176..
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag.
Ash wrote in this past week and he said,
as someone who was involved with the BSA as a boy many years
ago, I've followed your site for nearly a year
and I've used a lot of the insight you
share to teach my son what I think the BSA got right.
For a number of reasons, we've chosen not to be part of the BSA.
I'm still able to use scouting fundamentals with my son
with an alternative group that I work with.
The knowledge you share is still relevant,
even though we aren't involved in the BSA.
Well, that's good to hear, Ash.
Thanks,
I'm glad that you're finding this useful.
David Livingston is an adult volunteer with a scout troop
and he said: hi, Clark,
You've been busy.
I really like what you've done with the website, podcast
videos and the blog.
I think you've tapped into something here
and I certainly wish you tons of success.
Thanks, David.
Thanks for your vote of confidence.
They're always appreciated.
Ed Bruce is with Troop 38 in North Falmouth, Massachusetts.
He said a year ago I took over a scout master for our troop.
Prior to that I was an assistant scout master for three years
and the troop was primarily adult-led.
When I became scout master we switched to the patrol method.
I told the boys it was their meetings, their trips,
their courts of honor, their everything.
I told parents that their boys are amazing
and not to underestimate their abilities.
We had our first patrol camping trip last September.
I worried it wouldn't work, but I trusted those
more experienced than me and thank you, Clark.
I had pretty low expectations but it was a resounding success.
It wasn't perfect, but it's never going to be.
I still have adults that question the methods.
The troop meetings are a bit chaotic and disorganized.
The patrol leaders are frequently not prepared
or as prepared as we think they should be,
and they rush through their patrol portion of the meetings
so they can go outside and run around and play games.
See how smart these scouts are.
Ha, ha, ha ha.
Sometimes it seems they're just sitting around
and not doing much, but for most of our meetings
we have close to 100% attendance.
Many boys choose to skip other activities,
including sports, to come to meetings and to go camping.
They cover enough in the meetings
to prepare for the camping trips
and they learn by doing things that scouts do.
I've seen incredible growth in all the boys
in the last year.
My senior patrol leader has grown into a caring
and responsible servant leader.
So don't sell your scouts short.
embrace the patrol method.
It's a lot of work at first, but the rewards are great.
and don't listen to the naysayers.
I'm sorry to ramble on,
but I wanted to make sure that Clark knows
how much of an impact he's had on our program.
Just think of the others that are out there
that haven't said anything.
Thanks again,
And Ed, thank you so much.
I certainly appreciate that
and I'm really pleased that you're finding things useful
and applicable and that they're working.
That's the most important thing, isn't it?
As I mentioned just a moment ago,
thoughts on scouting-
Thoughts on scouting- is my first book.
How about that?
Yes, a real book with pages and a cover
and all that kind of stuff.
And I mean, for the past 30 years
I have really enjoyed being a volunteer scouter
and I've been maintaining the blog
and the podcast for about the past eight years
and I have a fondness for sayings and maxims
and adages and mottos and epigrams
and proverbs and aphorisms.
I think there's a lot of poetry and beauty
and challenge in expressing a really complex thought
in a few well-chosen words.
So all of the thoughts in this book-
the title is Thoughts on Scouting
and you can go to scoutmastercgcom
find out how to get your copy-
All of the thoughts in that book-
there's 150 of them-
were first published as 140 character-long tweets-
Tweets
And it's been great fun to watch them
take on a life of their own.
I've put the book together to get you
thinking about your work in scouting
And maybe even
I've put the book together to help you.
I've put to the book together
so that you have something
that helps you think about what you're up to in scouting
and maybe provides a little bit of inspiration.
I've based a lot of my Scoutmaster Minutes
on those thoughts
And I've even used some of them
to liven up a training session or two.
I tried to keep things cheerful
because I don't like to take myself too terribly seriously,
and I've thrown in a funny one or two.
Not every idea in the book is new,
not by a long shot,
and I doubt many are original.
I can tell you I haven't consciously used
anyone else's material,
but you know what they say:
good writers borrow and great writers steal.
Since people do ask, if you get the book
and you wanna use any of the sayings in it
or thoughts in it in a newsletter or on your website,
go ahead. go ahead.
It's all freely offered to advance the work of scouting,
and that's what it's all about, isn't it?
So, once again, the title of the book
Thoughts on Scout, and go to scoutmastercgcom.
find out how to get your copy,
and I really appreciate all of you
who have already ordered a copy
since we announced the publishing of it last week.
Sure, do appreciate that
In this podcast we're going to talk about the.
this is a little dramatic, folks.
We're gonna talk about the Troop Program Death Spiral,
And we've got an email question to answer,
So that's gonna take up the rest of the podcast.
So let's get started. shall we
Scouts master ship in seven minutes or less.
So what is the Dreaded Troop Program Death Spiral?
I mean, that's kind of a dramatic way of putting it,
but I got your attention though, didn't I?
Why do some troops get off track
and begin to lose scouts
and the program just kind of folds in on itself.
I think there's a predictable sequence of events
that kind of lead to that spiral down to the crash.
I'll begin by saying
I don't think scouts are ever the problem.
I think it's the way we work with them
that causes most of the problems.
So let's go back to when we signed on as a volunteer
and we start working with a scout troop.
I know many of you started working with a Cub Scout pack.
but let's go back to when you start
working with a scout troop.
So you go to training and you work at understanding your role
and you evaluate the current practices of the troop
against what you learn and you work at it, you try.
Now that's one way to approach your role
as a scouting volunteer.
Another way is not getting trained
and not really learning about your role
and just kind of adopting whatever practices
that were present when you signed on.
And then a third way is to assume
that we already know everything
and we carry on regardless.
or we're working with people who assert
that they know everything and we follow them.
Either way we resist examining
or improving on what we're doing.
So, once again, you can get trained
and try and really work at this
and try and understand things.
or you can not get trained
and not bother to learn anything
and just kind of follow along with whatever's happening
in the troop that you're serving in,
or you can just assume that you know everything
and carry on and work with people
who assume they know everything.
What I would like us all to do
is to examine what we're up to
and improve on what we're doing.
Now, nearly every scouting volunteer
is going to hear something about
the mysterious patrol method
or the virtues of a boy led troop
and they may commit themselves
to understanding and applying the patrol method.
Now this is a really crucial juncture here,
because Baden Powell said that the patrol method
or the patrol system-
those terms are pretty much interchangeable-
was the one essential element of scouting.
and it's not easy to understand
because really you really don't see
the patrol method applied in youth groups
outside of scouting.
So it takes some time to understand.
So you hear about it,
you commit yourselves to applying the patrol method
and then they apply the concepts
in the practice of the patrol method
and the first results are almost always disappointing.
From the adult perspective they're pretty disappointing.
The scouts they're pretty happy with things.
but from the adult perspective,
when you look at the way this works,
when you have put everything
in the hands of the scouts
and you're working on getting them to be responsible
for doing their own thing,
they're gonna look kind of incapable
or competent or lazy.
They're gonna look too young-
and we've got to accept the fact that they are young
and their efforts are gonna be kind of disjointed
and chaotic and they're gonna fall far short
of creating that orderliness and efficiency
that adults imagined we would create, right.
So we know that youth leadership
is not going to be a smooth, orderly, efficient affair
most of the time and we look at that
and we don't see the chaotic kind of uncertainties
as a positive indication of growing and developing leaders.
Now we look at it and we're kind of disappointed
and it's a little scary, you know,
And it just it seems purposeless. sometimes
We look at that and we say,
well, this whole patrol method thing,
this whole boy led thing,
I think it's a great idea, but really, you know,
we've got to do a lot more supervising here.
Once we're not too sure about this whole patrol method thing
and we start to interfere a little bit,
we start to run things,
we try and make things more efficient and orderly,
As we do. that you know, the more we do,
the better. the more efficient things are
and the more orderly they are
and there's less trouble and uncertainty and chaos,
The Scouts are gonna be happy
to have those things taken care of for them.
They won't complain,
They'll have fun and they won't have to do a whole lot.
Boys like that kind of thing for a little while,
but eventually they're gonna get bored.
and then the next step in the spiral
is the adults have to start coming up with more new
and even more entertaining experiences,
because Scouts are gonna leave if they don't,
and so they work at this.
and then the adults tend to get a little upset
when the Scouts don't properly appreciate
all that's being done for them
and this turns to frustration
and that frustration can harden into resentment
and that kind of resentment
can lead to all kinds of negative things.
You can have a bad attitude about Scouts.
You can start making a lot of rules
because you're gonna coerce them
into properly appreciating all the wonderful things
that you're doing for them.
You know what I'm saying?
It's that step,
That's just one of the twists of the spiral,
and that kind of attitude drives a lot of Scouts away.
and then, when Scouts start to leave,
adults become even more upset and resentful.
and adults are already fatigued
from trying to hold things together
and doing everything.
their energy starts to wane
and things kind of spiral down.
So how do we avoid this?
Well, we need to get trained.
but getting trained is not enough.
We can't just passively receive these ideas.
We have to test them,
We have to pick them apart,
We have to learn about them.
and I'll tell you the truth-
and a lot of people agree-
that our present training doesn't do a very good job
of getting the patrol method across.
So you've gotta go a little bit over and above
and you've gotta read about it,
You gotta think about it,
You gotta test it.
Then you have to apply the concepts
and observe the results
and assess the understanding and then try again.
And you need to do this with a group of adults
who are committed to making that kind of thing happen.
And then you need to stick with the process
and work to understand it
and you'll avoid that downward spiral.
You come into your role as a volunteer,
you get started,
you try out this youth led patrol method kind of stuff.
It looks chaotic and messy
and you begin to slowly take over
and then the scouts
they're happy for a while.
then they get bored with what you're doing.
So you try and amp it up
and you try and do more interesting things
and that takes a lot of energy.
and then you get a little resentful
when they don't properly appreciate all the energy
that you're putting into it.
Maybe you start making rules
and then the scouts
they don't really care for all that
and they're going to start to leave.
and once the first couple do,
you grow resentful about that
and the scouts pick up that attitude
and pretty soon
you've got nothing to work with.
So getting off on the right foot
is going to be important.
Learning what your role is
as a scout leader is going to be important,
and really dedicating the time to it
and working with it
and understanding that it takes time
and patience.
it takes a high tolerance
for adversity and uncertainty.
But stick to it,
strive to understand it
and you're going to stay out of the spiral.
Boy Scouts,
Boy Scouts.
Find me a letter,
send it my name.
Email that is folks.
and here's an answer to one of your emails.
So this email question came in,
I'm going to withhold the name and the location.
Here's what the writer said.
So our troops been using a patrol method
for about a year
Now. I really like the concept, but my problem is
I don't agree with the hands-off policy,
meaning do not interfere with the patrols.
I've been rebuffed by our scout master
for stopping games that were getting too rough
in my opinion,
where I've pointed out things I thought can be approved on,
only to have the scout master tell me that I'm in the wrong
Now. I've been a den leader in Cub Scouts
and a Cub master.
I just started a new Cub pack
and I'm also an assistant scout master.
I've done a lot of training, including the scout master training.
Hands-off leadership might work
well with a group of older boys,
but I believe our younger scouts need supervision.
Our oldest scout is about 15
and the other boys are between 11 and 12..
Some of the decisions being made by these younger scouts
need to be gone over by the adult leaders.
Our troop meetings are very poorly planned.
I think they could spend their time much better.
I feel that I'm not really needed
and I don't know why I'm putting on a uniform
and showing up to these meetings
if I'm just going to sit there and watch.
It's a waste of my time.
Am I wrong to feel that these scouts need more supervision?
I know my son is only 12
and he has sometimes has trouble making the right decision.
Shouldn't we be much more involved with what's going on?
Well, I say that what you describe
is really sounds to me
like somebody is applying the patrol method,
the way that it should be applied,
and it doesn't look right, does it?
It won't,
You know it won't,
Leave the scouts alone
and follow the scout master's lead for now.
It's pretty typical
that people, especially people who've been involved with Cubs,
are going to get into a scout troop
using the patrol method and using youth leadership
and they're going to have a lot of reservations
about what's going on
and they may not understand what's going on.
What looks like 45 minutes of playtime
may be something else,
and if it was only 45 minutes of playtime,
well, you have to sit back and you have to say:
what are our scouts doing?
How are they developing themselves individually
and their patrol as a group?
The age of the scouts matters a little bit,
but not as much as everybody may think.
Younger scouts can manage much more
than we are comfortable with letting them manage.
You know, a lot of times-
especially if you're a parent-
the younger scout trying to manage
buying food and cooking food
and things like that boy.
it just seems really, really sketchy
and it's a tough thing to do.
but you know what they do, fine.
They do fine.
They plan a meeting and hold a meeting
and things like that.
Of course you're going to look at that.
if a boy who's 12 years old plans a meeting,
He's not going to plan it to an adult standard,
He's going to plan it to a 12 year old boy standard,
which means he is going to plan it
to have the most fun
and to efficiently get through
whatever business he needs to get through
so that they can go out and run around and play.
Of course he's going to do that.
Now you work with them.
so you work with them, of course,
but if they're getting done what they need to get done
and they're happy with it,
let's move on.
I understand you feel like you're wasting your time,
but you and I wear a uniform to do one thing
and one thing only,
and that's to make it possible for scouts
to do the real work of scouting
In a scout troop. that means doing things
with some adult oversight
but independent of adult interference.
If you don't agree with the scout master's assessment
of the scout's abilities
and the way that he's administering things,
you can choose to accept that
you may be wrong
and see if you may be able to learn something
from this experience,
or you can honestly find another troop
that more closely reflects the way you want to do things.
I'm not trying to be dismissive of your concerns.
There are plenty of troops out there
that are run on a very efficient basis
by the adults
and then there are other troops
that are run on the patrol method by the boys.
You're going to see a huge difference
between the two.
if one more closely reflects
what you think scouting should be,
go to that one.
It's really pretty simple:
Training. just as I said
in scout master's ship in 7 minutes
or less just a moment ago.
training is very important
and it's an important source of knowledge,
but being trained does not mean
that you possess experience or skill.
Volunteering as a cub leader
is a wonderful service,
but you have to understand that cub scouts
do things appropriate to their age level
and
scouts do things appropriate to their age level.
Experience as a leader
at one level does not mean
that you know or understand
anything about what happens
at the next level.
What you might need to do is kind of shift out a cub scout gear
and work at understanding
how a scout troop really works.
You've got to have a lot of patience
and tolerance for the kind of chaos
that this looks like.
You have a tight schedule and you don't feel as if you're needed-
and this may very well be true,
honestly, because scout troops need
fewer adults involved.
Perhaps you should concentrate on the cub pack
and share scouting with your son,
go camping every now and then
show up at a meeting when you can.
in fact, you might found out that it's a lot less
frustrating and a better time for the both of you.
So, honestly,
I'm not trying to be dismissive of
anyone's concerns about this.
I'm just trying to explain what happens
not to uncommon in troops that use the patrol method,
that parents are going to be concerned
and new volunteers are going to be concerned
over the way things happen.
My best advice is to hang on,
study and be open to learning
what's happening. Sometimes
adult volunteers are going to be oil and water
for each other and if you don't really understand
or appreciate or agree with what's going on.
you may really want to think about
helping another troop. So, anyways,
I hope that helps. if you have a question for me,
you can get in touch and you'll find out
how to do that in just
music.
Thanks so much for listening to this edition
of the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Well, here's how to keep in touch.
read the Scoutmaster blog at
scoutmastercgcom
While you're there. you can subscribe to receive updates
to the blog by email. You can subscribe
to the Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes
and access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio.
You get details about how to do that
at stitchercom. You can
experience the wonders of ScoutmasterCGcom
through the vast panorama of
social media outlets. Follow
us at ScoutmasterBlog on Facebook,
Tweet ScoutmasterCG on Twitter
and go to YouTube
and watch our videos at
ScoutmasterCG on YouTube
for the admittance to the exclusive
ScoutmasterCG circle.
search for ScoutmasterCG
on Google Plus
and you can always email me if none of the
social media stuff appeals
to you. That's right. Zoom
into the 90s and drop me
a message at Clark
C-L-A-R-K-E
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
That's Clark
C-L-A-R-K-E
at ScoutmasterCGcom.
The Scoutmaster blog and the
Scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America,
and it's just me talking into
a microphone and trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders and maybe have a little
bit of fun along the way. Speaking of fun,
let's hear from our founder, Sir Robert.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Thank you, sir,
Until next time.